Bit of a bit of a game show theme kind of thing
here. I guess we can, down in the comments,
what do you think this dice is for? Or why would
we make these things?
- (Brady: Look at them all! Look atthem!)
Yeah each thing you make, right, you've got
to make a mold, you got to get them made; like
you got to be making thousands of them at once
otherwise there's no point of doing it so why
would we bother doing this? What was the point?
So we'll start out with these, let's give them
a good old roll there. So um so yeah what what
is the point of these and why- we'll start off
easy. Some of these are quite obscure but these
ones are hopefully not that difficult. What are
these for?
- (I don't know, what are they for?)
- Well uhI mean you can see the numbers on them, well this one
says- if you look on the top, I guess there isn't
a face on the top but you can still got a number.
Sort of similar to the ordinary 4-sided die is
like just a pyramid, and- cos it doesn't have a face
on the top you put numbers either around the base
or up at the tip because you don't have a face. But
that's fine, you can still pick a random number
by by doing that. And so these are just 6-sided
dice that are not the usual cube but why not?
There's like a triangular pyramid on the top
so that's three of your sides and there's another
three on that side - it's just another way to do a
6-sided die which isn't a cube. Cos, you know, why
stick with cubes? This works as well.
- (So there's)
(no advantage or disadvantage or anything to this?
It's just a just a-)
- It's just a different way to
do. Um maybe there is an advantage, I don't know. Is it
is it easier to pick up? Maybe slightly, I don't
know. Is it more painful to step on? Possibly.
- (Harderto pack)
- Harder to pack, that's true, they don't stack
together nicely and make- actually you know what,
I've never tried this. I don't think they do - yeah
there's a gap there, that's that's no good. Because
you know everybody sticks the usual cube, it's
traditional, but what are the other possibilities?
There's another way you can do it.
- (What shape isthat?)
(What is that name of that shape?)
- Um I wouldcall it a bi-pyramid or triangular bi- pyramid. Well
right, so the the the thing you need for the the
die to be fair is - do we say die or dice? I never
figure it out, whatever. The thing you need for dice
to be fair is that well all the faces have to be
the same and you know the the they're sort of all
arranged relative to each other in the same way
right; so you can get from any face to any other
face by just sort of rotating it around. And that
is true for this shape as well, just as it is for
the cube. All right, so that's number one. All
right, next one. What is- what is thisthing?
So um it looks kind of like a spinning top.
(Again, how do I know what number you've rolled?)
- Well it isn't super- it's easier in person but
I mean I can see that this is a 20 on the topand-
- (So it's the number that's-_
- It's the number
that's on the top. Right, so that's a 2. Again
maybe not the easiest, it's easier when you're
when you're in person and you have like you know
depth perception and stuff like that. Well and how
many sides does it have? This side you can see, it's
got all of the odd numbers - oh except it doesn't,
there's a 16 there. All right, a lot of odd numbers
and there's a lot of even numbers on that but
there are 20 sides. So this is just a 20-sided die.
Why would you- but it's so horrible right? The the
the 20-sided die that people like is the classic,
the icosahedron, right. The the- I think some people
would say it's the prettiest of the dungeons and
dragons dice. Why would you do this? Well there's
a reason, which is that we have- I think we talked
about in some previous video, the skew D6. It looks
like a ordinary cubical die but it is messed up
and distorted - but still fair. Right, that's the
sort of mathematical uh point to this, is that you
you want to distort it a little bit but still have
it be fair. And so there's the 8-sided fair but
distorted and and the 4-sided fair but distorted.
That one's actually I think an improvement on the
usual 4-sided die because there's a big number
on the top unlike the usual 4-sided die, you get
these like fiddly little things around. Anyway. And
then there's the distorted 12-sided die and
the to to round out the the classic dungeons and
dragons set is a set of seven dice - no icodahedron
for you - with a four, a six, uh an eight, a twelve, the
two 10 siders so you do percentages and the D20.
And the problem with this, so why is this the the
cursed D20? All of the other shapes you take the
standard shape and you distort it just a little
bit and it's still fair, you can still make a fair
die out of it. But the D20, the icosahedron, that turns
out there's no way to do it. There's no way to like
tweak this just a little bit and have it still be
fair, it breaks the the symmetry. We knew we had
to do the full set, the full classic set, but
there was just no way to break the D20 and so we
just had to okay we're going to lean into it, just
make this horrible horrible thing the the best you
can do is two 10-sided pyramids stuck back to back,
that's all you can do. So we had to.
- (So you wantedto have a set of dodgy dungeons and dragon dice? And)
(the only way you can make a dodgy 20-)
- Is to go tothis thing. That's what you have to do. You can't
tweak it just a little bit, doesn't work.
- (That makessense, okay)
- Good good for your like Call of Cthulu
games where everything's like eldritch and weird.
- (What's next?)
- So these, all the same but uh these - we
were just talking about fairness of dice, do theselook fair?
- (No they look- uh hard to tell. They don't)
(really look particularly symmetrical)
- Right. The-yeah I mean the the shapes on the faces are all
different. So this one here, 18, that's a rectangle.
And 17 is a triangle and 16 is like a kite shape.
They're all different, so yeah there's no reason;
and actually I have no idea how fair this is, we
never tested it for rolling because these are
not for rolling. Okay what else do people use
dice for? So these are used for keeping track of
your score or your life points. So these are called
countdown dice, or sometimes you call them spin down dice.
Maybe you start with 24 Health points and then
you're playing Magic the Gathering or something and
then you take some damage and then you go down to
you got 22 health points - you just leave it on
there on the table so you know what you're doing.
Usually countdown dice look something like this,
so it's an icosahedron, starts with 20 because in
Magic you have 20- 20 life points. And then you go
down to 19 health points, and 18, and 17, and 16 and
it it follows like you know a nice path. So this
is numbered not the way that a usual die would
be, where they're like all over the place, because
you want to find oh what's the next number. And
the the the disadvantage of this is that you've
got three different directions to go - which which
way do you go? And then there's another weird thing
with this one: 13, 12, 11 - where's 10? Got 19 on this
side and 12 and 6; 10 is on the complete opposite
side because whoever made this die decided that
opposite sides should still out to 21 even though
you're not- anyway I don't know why they did this,
I mean this is a very first world problem. It must
be said but still you know you're trying to find the
next number and you don't know which way to go,
whereas uh the the new and improved version has
this nice path that that winds its way all the way
down to 1 and then back to 24. The design is sort of
related to these things called sphericons which
are these kind of like- maybe you've seen these,
they like it sort of rolls and it not a not
a polyhedron but sort of smooth things
where you kind of roll and it kind of wiggles
back and forth and this is doing the same sort
of thing but with the kind of uh polygonised
version so that you can you can do the dice.
(This seems like a bad way to keep track of your
score, cos you could so easily knock it and then)
(it's like - oh what what number was I on?)
- It's true,it's true. How stable is your table? Do you think
we can get it to go?
- (No. It's- it seems like the
optimal design would be one that is hard to roll)
Right, right. And we did think about that, like you
know we wanted to maximise- right the shape is not
a standard polyhedron, like it came from somewhere,
so we definitely wanted to maximise the like the
tipping angle, right? How far do you need to move
the centre of gravity before it will be on the
tip? So right, you don't want to tip from 14 to 10,
like that, you don't want that to be easy. So that's
a really sharp angle and then the other ones we're
trying to like make them as much as you can. Well
and why is it 24? Right, why not 20? Because there
was a parity thing that you have to had to work
with yeah.
- (Creating the path, that nice optimal path
so you can easily go from 1 to 24 or 24 to 1,)
(was that a trivial mathematical problem? Or was
there some crunching involved?)
- So so there's a
couple of things; I mean first is just what is the
sort of the large scale? Like how many numbers are
going to be? How many times does it wind back and
forth? The original sort of idea for this came from,
there's a guy called Alexandre Muñiz, and he said
can you do just can you do a sphericon countdown
die? And the usual sphericon has these like two
kind of circles and it wobbles back and forth
like this - you go up, down, up, down and then you'd be
back at the start, so there would be like four of
these things. We started, we said oh that's a cool
idea, and then we started playing with it and then
immediately realised wait, there isn't a number
on top. So somehow the fact that if you go up and
down twice there's sometimes like a corner on top
or on edge. Whereas with three times this is what
this does: it goes up and down three times then you
always get a face on top. So that was not obvious
initially and then there was this whole other side
of like well how do you make the shape? How do you
decide what the angles are? And that that we used
um there's some like optimisation stuff to to do
with the 3D software that I use. You can generate
things that change the shape of stuff and and
try to optimise things, so that's what we did.
- (Nice, okay, next set)
- All right, next. This is uh - oh gosh,
nice and not not too complicated this one but it's
kind of fun to play with.
- (What we got here?)
- So what
are these about? So you will notice that there are
not numbers on these, instead there are letters. So
maybe you can guess what this is for?
- (Tryingto make a word?)
- You're trying to make a word, it's
sort of like a you know like a word game. Again not
so easy to tell which letter is on top necessarily,
but this is C, H, O, E and Z. Um so the Z might
be a problem. Uh what can we do? Uh the C isn't
fantastic either. Umm HE is a two-letter word.
- (Thiswill randomly generate you five letters?)
- Generally
you get five letters yes
- (And then you're going totry and make the longest word you can?)
- Right or
or, you know, play some sort of word game with us.
There's a bit of a cheat here; we gave you a U with
a Q because you know it's kind of difficult to
deal with the Q otherwise. There is something
uh interesting here, right, so the obvious comparison
is with Boggle right? Boggle has you know the grid
of of cubes and when you do that you can you can
like one cube is only going to have vowels on it-
so you know you're going to get some vowels. And
here we're like, okay we're going to make you know
one design and then they've all got to work for
this. So the distribution of the letters is sort
of the interesting part, right.
- (Oh so they're not- there's not 26 on each-)
- There's not 26 sides, right,
there are - well so we went for 60 sides cos what
we were going for is like, okay what can you do
that's the closest to the distribution of letters
in the English language? So obviously there's
going to be more E's and T's then there are going to
be Q's and K's and J's and so on. And so we went for
60 because- you know you could do this for 30, you
can make a 30-sided die but then you don't have
much wiggle room. Because you want at least one of
everything and then it's like, oh I've got my 26
and I got four extras okay which is going to be
E and T and like, it just isn't going to give you a
good distribution. So 60 is reasonable, we have
done 120 sides but it's a big expensive die and it's
kind of difficult to work with. And so this 60-sided
thing was the thing to go for.
- (Does each of the)
(five dice have the same distribution?)
- Yeah that'sone of the things in like the logistics of doing
this, is like making each die- you know you're going
to you- got to make a mold. And if you're going to
have- like I mean you could have different dice and
and you know get the distribution be better; but it
would be more expensive to generate a mold for
each one of them and so we all right, well what can we
do with one.
- (What is the distribution? Can we putit
on the screen or something or? Or is that like)
(your secret?)
- I mean it's not that secret cos youcan just look figure it out!
- (So can I put on the)
(screen what the distribution is?)
- Absolutely
- (So there's the Distribution on the screen)
(How did you come up with those numbers?)
- Well right, there's a bit of an interesting story
there as well. So this is essentially the same
problem as assigning seats in congress, because
you've got very small states who you know if you
went purely by the the numbers wouldn't have
any representation at all, you can't have that, so
you need to add one here and take away one here.
So who loses out and who gains? So obviously the
J's and the Q's and the Z's, they need to have a
bit of help cos otherwise you would't get any
- (Andthat's why we got a Z now)
- Right right yeah. So
it makes it more difficult and then you have to
take it away from somebody's, how do you do it? You
can say, okay you have to round down to get this
letter its number. So it deserves more so we'll
take away one from here or you know you can figure
stuff out like that.
- (When you were deciding,)
(when you were making these decisions, did you do
it purely mathematically or was there a bit of-)
(did you put a bit of thumb on the scale, personalpreference?)
- Uh there was no personal preference umm
but we're not linguists so I won't say that we did
it perfectly either. We just sort of, well it seems
sort of reasonable. The the the differences here
are sort of minor. There's also like, which, you know
what what body of words do you use?
- (Your corpus -is that what you call ir?)
- A corpus right. Should
it be just like the dictionary words or should it
be the words as they're used in ordinary English
language? Because it's different, if you're making
sentences, if you're writing a book, certain letters
are going to show up more often and if you just
look at the list of words in the dictionary. That's
different again, but these are all sort of minor
things like, you know maybe this you know N gets
one more or not or something like that. Ultimately
I think we did okay.
- (Do you enjoy playing the)
(game? Do you play it much?)
- Um as with many of the
things, I actually enjoy making the stuff more
than solving the puzzles but you know it's a fun
thing to have around. Next one. So this really is
sort of more of a puzzle of what it's for. So
I want to give you a chance to think about it.
This video continues with part two, an even more
ingenious dice to admire - there's a link in the
description. But if you like dice, well there are
plenty of courses and puzzles over at Brilliant
that are going to scratch that itch. For example
just take a look at some of these. Brilliant of
course is today's episode sponsor; it's full to the
brim with great courses and quizzes, all sorts of
riddles that are going to take you deep into the
world of mathematics, computer science and other
science subjects. One of the great things about
Brilliant content is that it's really interactive.
But it's not like a 'you must get this right' kind
of thing - it's more engaging, fun, playful. It's the
way learning should be. And there's always new
stuff being added to their huge collection.
If you want to check them out there's a free
30-day trial and Numberphile viewers can get
a 20% discount on their subscription by going to
brilliant.org/Numberphile. You can also give people
a subscription as a gift - a thoughtful present for
that inquiring mind in your family perhaps. Have a
look, there'll be a link in the description.
And good luck with all those puzzles about dice.
If you're interested in any of the dice you
saw in today's video, you can buy them actually.
I'll put a link in the description, you can
find out more stuff. I'll also put links to
other dice videos we've done in the past.
- Psy- psychological and sociological setting
suppose that you think you can control the
dice, of course you're not perfect at it...